so on the tour we've got three bands
guys say hey to the new group hello
we're the Bellas formerly of Barden
University and currently of life you
guys are seeing other people's songs
right oh my god um guys stop they just
don't like sharing the spotlight so
they're trying to intimidate us think
what I'm thinkin music a resource right
yeah
yes what is it a riff-off is a little
game that we like to play we start with
a beat oh yeah oh go ladies
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
with all my belly
[Music]
is that feedback so it's singing guys
still need that level check for vocals
we're not done yet
baby we're just getting started
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they just swallowed by themselves by
using musical instruments because I we
won guys we should go
we won fellas are doing what they do
best quitting here's the problem John
the Bellas are not as good as the other
bands that is a startling insight
all right ladies were going to show them
that we are not a joke
let's like a finish this try to have
some dignity we don't do anything with
dignity okay
what a beautiful everyone of them going
nowhere so what do you want us to think
tonight about this just a day we didn't
invite you guys to sing we invited you
to watch Alka scuse me I just thought
you guys were so busy with your awesome
jobs and amazing lives I am actually
[Music]
you're so bright and shinies they're
pretty they look like they was all
breastfed us focus on this performance
to support the troops in Europe one last
show together who is with me oh yeah
[Music]
welcome to Spain fellas so this is the
first base will we be going to second
base with you guys that's a no for me so
long at all we've got three bands you
guys are seeing other people's songs
right like a cover band they're trying
to intimidate us let's just do it to a
reef off
we like to keep it oral
everybody is better at the one thing
that we do then then we are at that
thing
all right ladies pick up your tests
we're going to show them that we are not
a joke my record label wants to sign one
of the bands but we don't want the
Bellas we want you what I did not see
this coming family we'd support each
other we like sisters Aubry
he is Oprah isn't it I can't I'm part of
a group Becca it's a big opportunity for
you
[Applause]
you
bye-bye fellas
it really does feel like goodbye John
Becca what are you doing don't ya if you
cry I'm gonna cry
don't make that face I'm not doing it
[Music]